tpr est marina à quoi à faire un petit
portrait mais pas chinois un anti
portrait chinetoques marine à marignane
si vous étiez un élément de salle de
bain je serai un petit à petit en
plastique vous savez des trucs tous
pourris là pour faciliter à la moi j'ai
un peu sale joker musiciens appareils
électroménagers je serai une touillette
electrica vinaigrette parce que c'est un
appareil pour les flemmards non j'aime
bien l'idée ce que c'est facile de
tourner à vinaigrette wallace et
électriques
d'accord je vous étiez inverse du
deuxième groupe pourrir pour y revoilà
très bien oui maintenant ont bruissé
troisième groupe
non mais alors expliquez moi je un
comment vous vous souvenez tout ça 2
quel intérêt se souvenir si vous étiez
un meuble de jardin
non je suis contre les meubles de jardin
si tu y as kobe décideurs 36 15 heures
idylle la santé de votre entreprise
inutile mirren récurrent de tf1 navarro
santiago jeune et je peux vous dire que
l'hernie chants et traits en prison si
vous étiez un des sept nains navarro si
vous étiez une prévision météorologique
jeu sera une grosse une mine énorme
dépression sur marseille au dessus de la
part de fait d'accord
divinity un cadeau de mariage un service
à fondue une friteuse que vous voulez
vous étiez un outil n'importe j'adore
les outils et là je suis très sérieuse
en jupette une costumes gérait
judicieusement